je pense que les valeurs des québécois
et des québécoises sont les priorités de
notre gouvernement
j'ai l'expérience qu'il faut pour
entasser simone et un plan pour aider
les familles lycée on a tout à gagner
un va-t-en pour des gens qui vont
défendre fondamentalement québec
c'est avec eux que ce changement va se
faire
vous les avez vus en plein milieu d'une
partie de baseball d'un téléroman d'une
émission de variétés elles sont partout
et ça ne fait que commencer
les publicités électorales certaines
sont classiques d'autres audacieuses ou
bien sûr négative quelles sont leurs
secrets
j'en discute avec notre panel de
stratège dominique vallier directeur des
relations de presse du bloc québécois
qui t'a québec robert asselin conseil
stratégique de justin trudeau vous êtes
à toronto aujourd'hui karl bélanger
conseiller principal de thomas mulcair
vous êtes à toronto également et
catherine loubier conseillère pour le
québec stephen harper à tahoua bon
dimanche à vous quatre
bonjour car là je commencerai avec vous
on le vu des publicités électorales
pendant ce début de campagne c'est une
longue campagne
est-ce que je rêve ou bien ce que comme
je disais on leur y ai vu encore avec
tout le monde un peu gardé ses munitions
pour le dernier droit
si certains que lors de la première
partie de la campagne à 7 et les télés
j'entends encore au chalet regardez pas
beaucoup la télé alors évidemment depuis
le retour à l'école si on peut dire
depuis la rentrée télévisuelle les côtes
des côtes augmente évidemment les
publicités vont vont être plus
percutants au niveau de l'impact au
niveau de l'auditoire qui se rejoint
vous savez manuel votre émission de très
bonnes cotes des crues parce que c'est
une excellente émission mais la plupart
des jeunes regardent pas les coulisses
du pouvoir et donc pour rejoindre foulée
rejoindre ailleurs et c'est pour ça que
comme vous l'avez au début on voit des
publicités dans d'autres raisons qui ne
sont pas dire l'information pour
rejoindre cet électeur qui ne
s'intéressent pas de très très très très
près à l'actualité politique
c'est ça que catherine parce que ce
succès qu'est ce qui est de rejoindre
justement un électorat qui ne
s'intéressent pas à la politique
davantage oui je pense qu'au début de
l'élection dans notre corps on veut
vraiment tabler sur la question dans les
eaux noires donc on veut vraiment dire
aux électeurs
voici le choix qu'on propose aux
canadiens aux québécois et puis c'est
important de le faire de manière assez
ferme donc ça peut être à la télévision
effectivement mais on mise aussi
beaucoup sur la radio on pense que la
radio est un moyen communiqué assez
important aussi puis
bien pourquoi c'est quoi l'avantagent la
radio bien en fait on pense qu'on peut
aller dans des marchés particuliers avec
la radio que ce soit la raison à
montréal où la réseau à québec où seul
en région ce sont des marchés différents
ou la radio joue un rôle différent ainsi
qu'à québec la radio où l'auteur crédit
aux à une grande influence les émissions
du matin à montréal aussi donc on trouve
sont efficaces sur les gens qui
conduisent au travail le matin et qui
reviennent le soir
et puis finalement sur le sur le web sur
l'internet c'est pratique également pour
prendre à la volée une erreur d'un
candidat de notre parti une gaffe comme
on dit est exagéré un peu cette gaffe là
par l'internet créé un peu un mouvement
autour de ça robert de votre côté on l'a
vu dans la facture des publicités du
parti libéral cette année un effort pour
sortir des sentiers battus certains ont
aimé d'autres ont un peu ridiculisé mais
il ya la pub de l'escalier celle avec
vos candidats dont on ne montre un
extrait est ce qu un double message dans
le fait d'aller dans une facture
différente
non au contraire je pense que l'idée
c'est d'être créatif d'aller chercher un
produit original que les gens m'ont
trouvé intéressant alors la cassette des
politiciens les gens sont habitués de
l'entendre mais surtout après certaines
quelques semaines dans la campagne ils
ont entendu les messages à nous y sommes
alors allés les chercher avec un créatif
un peu différent qui frappe l'imaginaire
des images d' équipe on a fait une pub
sur les garderies du npd montré que
d'enfoncer un mirage alors ça ça fait en
sorte que les gens comprennent un peu
mieux ce qu'on essaie de communiquer
avec une formule un peu différente
dominique du côté du bloc québécois on
le fait moins de publicité en ondes
moins de budget peut-être aussi est-ce
qu'il ya ça complique la donne pour vous
mais en fait ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
décidé de faire cette élection si ces
deux de prendre une bonne partie du
budget qu'on a pour les publicités et de
le mettre sur le web
de publicité avec facebook ça nous
permet de cibler des codes postaux ça
nous permet de cibler des
circonscriptions alors nous on se dit
innovons allons là dessus on a décidé à
chaque jour quand on sort des
communiqués on publie des images aussi
qu'ils reprennent qui reprennent nos
messages et ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
beaucoup cc reprises s'est partagé les
gens aiment les gens commentent
donc nous on crée on a décidé de prendre
une partie du budget pour l'affecter à
ça ça fonctionne jusqu'à date justement
est-ce qu'on voit davantage sur les
publicités sur le web ou s'il ya bien
sûr les publicités négatives tout le
monde aiment les détester mais elles
sont efficaces ont peut-être montré un
extrait de vos différentes publicités à
cet effet c'est la goutte de trop
je retourne au bloc
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre l 1
[ __ ] 2 mulcair commence mon coeur ne dit
pas ce que ces provinces cash ou comment
il va les payer son plan n'est rien de
moins que l'image
je vais recommencer je vais revenir avec
vous dominique valeyre j'ai lu quelque
part que cette publicité sur une cave
elle était faite pour le web et l'aurait
elle a eu un million de clics est ce que
c'est la preuve que ça peut être plus
efficace des fois de passer par les
médias sociaux
je pense que oui puis évidemment ça eu
l'impact qu'a eu parce que ça a été
repris par les médias traditionnels
mais cette publicité là la sphère et au
début on loge on va autoriser sur
facebook donc on a mis de l'argent pour
que les gens la voient mais en ce moment
on est à moins de 5 sous du clic
alors c'est extrêmement rentable
extrêmement rentable pour nous une
publicité comme celle-là oui si je vais
aux autres
robert par exemple est ce que on a
l'impression que les pubs sur internet
les pubs facebook elles sont plus
exagérer peut-être par part par moments
moins léché plus percutante on prend
plus de risques avec ces publicités à
contenu ou eliasson mais je dirais que
c'est surtout une question budget les
parties produisent beaucoup de publicité
la télévision est un médium de loin le
plus cher c'est coacher à acheter les
pubs à la télé donc les partis
choisissent de les envoyer vers les
médias sociaux qui ont une certaine
circulation de certaine efficacité
il faut comprendre que les médias
sociaux dans certains segments de la
population les personnes plus âgées par
exemple ça rejoint pas tout le monde
alors il faut avoir un mix d'un peu tous
les médias la télé la radio et les
médias sociaux
karl vous votre parti a fait le pari de
se moquer d'une publicité qui avait été
très efficace du parti conservateur
effectivement on reprend un peu la
publicité conservatrice qui ont fait du
judo avec un peu pour rappeler le
message fondamental cette élection si et
à propos de quoi qui peut remplacer
stephen harper parce que c'est le temps
de la remplacer alors on a pris un peu
la formule de l'humour qui nous promet
la publicité qui fonctionne toujours
bien les gens rigolent en regardant ces
publicités là parce qu'ils se souvient
évidemment la première publicité qui
était celle du parti conservateur et
donc c'est une arme qui toujours
efficace en publicité politique
catherine votre parti maîtrisent l'art
des publicités négatives je pense qu'on
peut le dire honnêtement
ce qui fait qu'une publicité négative
fonctionne par rapport à celles qui ne
fonctionnent pas écouté effectivement
c'est l'électeur qui nous renvoie le le
sentiment après une publicité quand on a
fait jason bay et ling
il est juste en visite au sujet de
ignatyev effectivement ça a été
extrêmement efficace
je vais garder mes commentaires pour
cette campagne si plus précisément mais
disons qu'on a utilisé le web beaucoup
pour démontrer qu est-ce que c'est le
npd les québécois n'ont jamais été
gouvernée par un gouvernement npd donc
on a voulu vraiment mettre sur la table
qui est en mousse manqué quelques
questionnements on doit avoir à son
sujet et qu'est ce que va donner un npd
puisque ça a été assez désastreux dans
d'autres provinces du canada donc on a
utilisé le web puis comme dominique
disait parfois utilisé le web
ça nous permet d'avoir une livraison en
direct à la télé parce que si c'est une
bonne pub effectivement il va se
retrouver au bulletin de nouvelles et la
plus part des auditeurs vont en avoir au
bulletin grande écoute
dominique par ailleurs la question que
je me pose quand ils utilisent le web et
tu te reste qu'on finit par ne parlait
qu'à nos propres partisans
ben nous on avait sept cette crainte là
en fait il faut toujours sortir de ce
qu'on a comme base avec monsieur duceppe
on a tenté beaucoup de faire augmenter
la portée de ces publications on a on a
eu je pense une dizaine de milliers de
personnes qui qui aiment la page de
monsieur duceppe depuis le début de la
campagne supplémentaire
même chose avec avec la campagne du bloc
et avec lafarge du bloc québécois pardon
alors évidemment il faut essayer de
sortir et une pub virale comme comme
celle qu'on a créés et comme d'autres
qui s'en viennent ça nous permet ça nous
permet justement de parler à autre chose
que strictement notre base vous êtes
averti robert il reste quelques secondes
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à une
augmentation du rythme des publicités
comme l'on est dans le dernier droit
oui absolument quelque chose qu'il faut
s'attendre c'est que les messages vont
évoluer selon comment la campagne va se
dérouler dans les dernières semaines
donc il faut comprendre que c'est pâques
années d'avancé on ajuste toujours les
messages et donc il va avoir des belles
surprises je pense si la fin de l'accord
carline reste quelques secondes je vous
donne un dernier mot là dessus mais les
publicités négatives si je peux
mentionner si tu vois ça peut être une
arme à deux tranchants
est-ce que ça va bénéficier aux partis
qui la propose vous aider un autre parti
ça reste à voir et des fois une
politique est trop négative voire
repoussé les gens dans le camp adverse
alors faut toujours faire attention avec
ces armes là à vous quatre jeux vous
remercier d'avoir été avec nous robert
catherine cas je vous laisse retourner à
la préparation de vos chefs pour le
débat de demain
merci au revoir drogba
que faire quand on est un candidat qui
doit couvrir des centaines de kilomètres
par jour voire par semaine pour faire
campagne pour rejoindre les électeurs et
bien en acadie un candidat libéral a
décidé de prendre les grands moyens
merlet martiaux la rencontre et le
candidat néo-démocrate d'acadie-bathurst
jason gaudin a choisi d'établir trois
quartiers généraux dans la
circonscription tellement et les grandes
pour faire face à ce défi géographique
le candidat libéral le ch cormier a
plutôt décidé de louer une roulotte à
chaque jour l'équipe transporte le
quartier général dans un village
différent
l'aventuré se déroule bien à quelques
désagréments
la seule chose des fois quand on fait du
café la petite génératrice a tendance à
penser un petit peu plus parce qu'on s'a
du café aux gens des choses comme ça
m'apporte ça va très bien puis c'est ce
que quelqu'un qui fait un peu plus
mauvais ou la pluie
c'est un petit peu plus difficile pour
piégeant vienne qui se déplace je vous
mets quand même si la visibilité que je
veux démontrer aux gens que je suis là
pour eux 11 pour la mère ce n'est pas
moins cher d'avoir un quartier général
mobile affirme l'équipe libérale et même
c'est plus compliqué à gérer que des
bureaux fixes
ça prend beaucoup de balles
à s'occuper de tout ce qui se passe
parce que lorsqu'on change de plats
changent de village il faut que d'autres
gens stockent s'informer alors c'est
beaucoup de logistique
mais ces belles fois il sait quand on
porte tous renvoient d'hôtes mende avec
merci d'avoir mis aujourd'hui vacants
dans la roulotte libéral effectue
environ 500 km de routes par semaine
sans aucun ennui mécanique majeur pour
l'instant le candidat serge cormier
espère que tout ce chemin parcouru le
différenciera suffisamment d autres
candidats pour le mener à la victoire
le premier débat français et change-t-il
la donne au québec et ailleurs au pays
après la pause le verdict de notre panel